In addition, Hart and Risley found that the children from the high income
families heard more praise words or encouragement words than did those from the
welfare families. Specifically, those from professional families heard a ratio
of six positive words to every one negative word. And those in the middle class
families, heard two positive words for every one negative word. For those from
welfare families, they heard one positive word for every two negative words. So
not only did type of family status play a role in the number of words on
average children heard per hour and the number of words they heard per year.
They also found that the type of words, positive and encouraging, versus
negative and discouraging, different among family type. This is an excellent
demonstration of how the environment or nurture can have a great impact on our
vocabulary. So, why is vocabulary size important. Well, Hart & Risley found in
their longitudinal research that the vocabulary size of the children at age
three demonstrated a strong positive correlation to language test scores at
ages nine and ten. In vocabulary, listening, syntax, and reading comprehension.
This study nicely demonstrates the importance of nurture or the environment on
language.